the streets of gaza have returned to
life after three days of warfare
the israelis targeting the personnel and
possessions of a group called islamic
jihad
so we try to make contact with their
leaders
these are not easy people to meet but
we've had a call from islamic jihad a
member of their political wing and
we're hoping he'll give an interview
a location was given at the last minute
for members of this movement are subject
to attack
who is responsible for
the recent
fighting
is
the israelis described their military
operation called breaking dawn as an
outstanding success killing two senior
members of islamic jihad but al-bash
foreign
but islamic jihad is not unarmed they
launched a thousand rockets at the
israelis although israel says many of
their weapons malfunctioned causing
significant
abbas has tried negotiating for a
palestinian state but islamic jihad has
no time for deal-making
there has to be a better way you could
accept
israel's existence
know that the violence will return and
some are making preparations john sparks
sky news on the gaza strip